hydrogen helium lithium beryllium boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen fluorine ners
we're really excited because we've just
hit 50,000 subscribers from periodic
videos and first of all we would like to
thank all of those who are supporting us
for watching and we're also really
pleased that there is more and more
chemistry coming up on YouTube brady has
just shown me a video rap about the
periodic table I think it's the first
rap song I've ever watched the rapper
has very generously said we can share
some of his music and show you some of
it so here we have updated his rap with
some of our videos
I must say that rap is not really my
seed but on the other hand if you're a
chemist you've always got to be
versatile your mind is a bit like soup
it has to be stirred up all the time I
don't think I go you say me rapping but
on the other hand hydrogen helium then
lithium beryllium boron carbon nitrogen
oxygen fluorine and neon and sodium
magnesium aluminium silicon phosphorus
and sulfur in an oven and then potassium
calcium scandium titanium vanadium
chromium manganese receives the iron
nickel copper zinc gallium and germanium
arsenic selenium bromine is descriptor
every elements can be recognized by its
protons the chemistry is basically the
swapping of electrons number in the
shell determines the reactants are able
to occur if in atomic interactions
hydrogen helium then lithium beryllium
boron carbon nitrogen oxygen fluorine
and neon and sodium magnesium aluminium
silicon phosphorus and sulfur and
chlorine and argon and then potassium
calcium scandium titanium vanadium
chromium manganese receives the il buco
opposite gallium and germanium arsenic
and selenium bromine by this is critical
tone elements of the periodic table and
the first repairs the most reactive
alkali metals present in fear that we
using the batteries and sodium